we just kind of we got tired of hearing
how good their defense was i mean and
they they deserve that that phrase
because how good they are but i mean we
we are good too and we just want to let
the world know that we are
that's josh jacobs of the raiders i
don't know the cameraman was hiding
behind a reporter but still we we got a
little sound and a little glimpse of
josh jacobs there as the raiders took
down the bears they clearly made a
statement they may make their way into
the sunday statement draft it's become a
weekly staple here for mondays during
football season and the new approach if
you haven't been watching for a while we
got rid of the coin toss yeah trivia
question time and
i will pose the question to you if you
get it right you get the first pick if
you get it wrong i get the first pick
jay gruden has been fired after
washington dropped to owen five this
year
he went to the playoffs one time and was
on one in a playoff game who is the last
washington head coach to actually win a
playoffs oh
this is in my wheelhouse because it came
against me okay so i like this one joe
gibbs
yeah damn that's just like that's great
that i got it right but you had to bring
that up huh i mean and i was going to
suggest a tougher question because i
thought this one was too easy right i
thought now you know what a little salt
in the wound 14 years i never heard it
yeah yeah i've never heard anybody damn
that still hurts me actually it does
you've told me that before yeah it still
bothers me it still bothers me because
we i truly believe we were the better
team uh and that's no i'm not trying to
like disrespect him they were a good
team too how far could you have gone uh
that was a year where i mean i think we
could have gone to seattle and played in
the nfc championship at the very least
seattle was the best team in the nfc i'm
not going to say we've gone there and
beaten them carolina ended up playing in
them in the nfc championship who was
second to us in the south that year
uh so i don't know if we would have beat
them but i think we could have gained at
least a tough time uh so that that hurt
that definitely hurt and then of course
the next year i got hurt and not life
was never the same
okay ready are you done yes i'm good all
right shut down memory lane over um make
your pick i mean i think i got to go
with the
i got to go across the ponte london to
the old chaps in london okay because
we've got 20 more emails coming yeah
good
but the the raiders i just got to say
that i think that was the biggest sunday
statement overall i mean yeah we didn't
know really what to expect the raiders
we i think we all thought that the bears
maybe got on track last week against the
minnesota vikings you know the defense
played so well chase daniel seemed to
manage the game um there's just so much
talk out there that you know matt nagy
and his full offense is in when when
chase daniel's in okay great um but the
the the raiders the physicality they
brought to the football game and really
pushing around the bearish front seven i
think was one of the shockers of the
week so for them to go over there really
win that game and and really what
controlled the game they kind of screwed
it up with a toss fumble that gave him a
one play touching touchdown drive uh had
another turnover that set up a short
field for or you know just a punt return
that set up the short field for the
bears uh so the raiders are my sunday
statement yeah i mean it wasn't just
building that 17-0 lead it was hanging
on once the bears came back because
other teams would have just said oh well
yeah we gave it our shot it's inevitable
the bears are going to win right we can
take some pride in the fact that we were
up no they hung with it 13-play 97-yard
drive to win the game i gotta go with
sunday night football yeah and i gotta
go with the colts right frank reich
right yeah uh a guy who is very
accustomed to that underdog role a guy
who relishes
people writing him off
and you know they they he was the
perfect coach for the job the way things
worked out nearly two years ago when
josh mcdaniels bailed out and it's
working even without andrew luck it's
working and yes they lost to the raiders
last week and i don't know how that
happened and i still don't know how that
happened but they went to kansas city
and that big wall they built got it done
yeah they controlled the time of
possession they kept patrick holmes on
the field they switched from their
primary defensive zone to man to slow
things down right and they just managed
to do it you know it was the first time
in 25 games in the regular season that
the chiefs hadn't scored at least 25
points 13 last night credit to the
defense credit to the offense credit
coaching staff the colts stunned
everybody last night was the first time
that i can remember
that
we were all unanimous in our picks on
football nightmare i knew that was a
disaster when it happened
when we all went there i i don't even
know if you heard me at the end of the
show i said uh oh cause that's never
good when you're that you when you're
unanimous you're usually setting up for
a disaster but i'm with you that was
definitely one of the statements of
yesterday uh colt's team back against
the wall they went in there and and
really put in an impressive showing okay
i think i'm going to go uh
with my boy aaron rodgers i knew i i
thought about it i thought about it i
got to i mean just hey green bay you
know you come off a heartbreaking
thursday night loss to the philadelphia
eagles and you're starting to go oh okay
gosh man their defense got torched you
know uh the offense looked good in that
eagles game but man will they be able
and the eagles defense banged up you're
going man are they gonna be able to go
down to dallas and and win a football
game down there against dallas who just
came off a loss you figured they'd be
pissed off and you know crossing the t's
and dot in the eyes but uh really green
bay
causing turnovers on the defensive side
of the ball aaron jones rushing you know
rogers especially in the first half
nothing there in the pass game without
devonte adams made some rogers type
plays where he bought time and made some
incredible throws down the field you
know uh
so i just looked at that to go into
dallas and then at some point be up
31-3 in dallas
nobody expected that i know that and i
just think that was a statement that
officially says
green bay's for real you know
we knew they were good and they're a
work in progress and things are you know
but i think this kind of says okay green
bay is going to be here for the long
haul this year they're not going
anywhere especially because they got it
done without devante adams i was very
skeptical of their ability to win the
game they have their running game now
with aaron jones four touchdowns over
100 rushing yards and the offense is
getting better that was the one thing we
said is they were winning games early
with an offense that was sluggish
money in the bank
because the offense eventually is going
to improve now the defense gave up over
500 yards yesterday and a lot of it was
in garbage time yeah but still the
defense needs to hold its end the
offense needs to hold its end that's
something aaron rodgers said before the
eagles game and they did lose to philly
but they seem to be in very good shape
all right i'm going to go with desean
watson yeah because yeah all this talk
about patrick mahomes and russell wilson
i think we had a couple mvp candidates
force their way into the conversation
yesterday with deshaun watson and
christian mccaffrey right especially
given that patrick mahomes lost and was
banged up and may i'm not i'm not gonna
say he's gonna miss time
but he may not be a hundred percent yeah
and that may show in his performance
moving forward but watson was 28 for 33
426 yards five touchdowns
158.3 passer rating that is perfection
and he averaged 12.9
yards per attempt that is incredible and
14 of those passes were completed to
will fuller who had three touchdowns and
217 yards proving that it is not a
one-man show in that passage
right deandre hopkins had seven catches
for 88 yards and no scores and i guess
sometimes it's hard to sit there and
watch that all play out but it worked
yeah and they won and they're three and
two and somebody's got to separate in
the
afc south yesterday we saw the colts and
the texans win and we saw the titans and
the jaguars lose and maybe it's going to
come down to the texans in the cold yeah
it could it could i just watson's
amazing i mean when i just really look
at football right now i just go you know
watson russell wilson mahomes aaron
rodgers they kind of stand above the
rest i think at the quarterback
positions they're kind of in their own
elite little class there uh because they
can just do things that other guys in
the sport can't at this point and watson
is a true superstar it was phenomenal
yesterday and billy o'brien i mean
he just always answers the bell i mean
he really does he's a hell of a football
coach i wish they were a little more
creative on the offensive side of the
ball and maybe yesterday jump starts
that a little bit but by the way yeah
next week right texans chiefs i know
patrick holmes deshauwn watson
back to back in the 2017 draft yeah and
uh i think number one number four will
be motivated for that one uh so all
right my my next statement i think i
gotta go with teddy bridgewater here
okay teddy bridgewater new orleans
saints you know
to win a game against the tampa bay
buccaneers who came off a big win
against the rams but teddy bridgewater i
think
calmed us all uh on sunday to go oh yeah
he can orchestrate the offense and he
can strike when people are open and uh
he really did a great job and and played
the best game maybe we've ever seen him
play really in the nfl to this point
because in minnesota he was a more of a
game manager yesterday he made some big
time plays and throws all right i agree
with you completely and you know he gave
a lot of credit to sean payton i'll talk
to him after the game sean payton knows
where everyone's going to be on the
field he draws up that game plan and
somebody still got to execute right and
teddy bridgewater came in and got it
done he said his knee feels better than
it did before that injury in august of
2016. he's come a long way and he's
setting himself up to be a starter next
year and the dilemma that the saints
will potentially face after this season
do we squeeze one more year out of drew
brees
or do we say drew you know what we're
just going to stick with teddy
bridgewater because it may very well be
that teddy decides i'm going to go
somewhere else right for 2020.
especially
and we're a long way from this happening
but what if the team that drafted him
decides yeah we'll have you back we'll
bring it back right you got to make the
last pick well and i am making the last
pick and then we're about to go
commercial no i wasn't no i was let's go
kevin stefanski okay the vikings
offensive coordinator not you kirk
cousins not well listen this guy's in
the middle of all of the crap that's
right last week
and he's got a deal with kirk cousins
adam felix stefan diggs he's got to deal
with the fact that the offense was crap
the week uh earlier against the bears
right and he's getting ready to to face
pat shurmur
who was the offensive coordinator when
stefanski was the quarterback's coach so
there's a little little of that going on
a little extra pressure right got to go
on the road got to deal with all the
dysfunction head coach is expecting you
to infuse balance into the offense you
know mike zimmer as as hands off as any
coach who specializes in one side of the
ball is
and i think stefanski
may have made
a solid case yesterday for head coaching
consideration next year because he did
on the offensive side of the ball what
head coaches have to do all the time
which is spin all the plates right
manage all the issues and on sunday make
it all work yeah it definitely did i'm
not going to go as crazy as you say it's
going to head coaching candidates he was
a candidate for cleveland last year they
were stupid for making them a candidate
and still got to see more because they
looked like crap last week and they
looked like crap a few other times on
the offensive side of the ball but it
was a good start for your vikings
nonetheless well and i don't think he's
gonna last yeah but it was a statement
yesterday i don't think it's gonna last
they could have lost after everything
that went on i was not gonna be shocked
if they had lost yesterday and
because you're doomsday no i'm not i'm
realistic you're always looking like
realistic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports